welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down Black Knight on Netflix in
case you've not seen it no it's not that
Martin Lawrence movie from the nories
this is actually a new Korean
post-apocalyptic drama that feels like a
mix between Mad Max the Hunger Games
X-Men and a lot more there's so much to
talk about and throughout this video
we're gonna be going through it all to
break down everything full spoilers
ahead so if you haven't had a chance to
check it out then I highly recommend
that you check out now please hit the
thumbs up button and if you enjoy the
video make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day by the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get in the Black Knight now the
series takes place in the aftermath of a
comet that hit the earth 40 years ago
this decimated the landscape and
completely destroyed the atmosphere
leading to oxygen becoming the planet's
most valuable commodity most continents
sunk into the sea with a cream Peninsula
now becoming a desert with just one
percent of the population left a new
social structure was created in which
some members of the public a given QR
code tattoos that give them a higher
ranking this is demonstrated by the use
of an upside down triangle in the intro
which actually becomes symbolic later on
I'll talk about this more as we get into
the video but a big mystery in the
season centers around the triangle
tattooed Soldier is that we meet
throughout now the entire populace is
divided up into the status of core
General and Refugee which becomes
important at the end the whole society
is heavily reliant on soldiers known as
delivery men who are basically Amazon
Prime drivers that are allowed to carry
guns now they take things like oxygen
and supplies from one location to the
next and are basically the backbone of
this new world when watching this I
couldn't help but think of the essential
workers I kept everything going through
the pandemic and because of this the
delivery men have access to almost
everything now those that weren't chosen
to be part of the system will label this
refugees and these outcasts were forced
out in the harsh Landscapes with a lot
of them becoming Hunters that attempt to
steal supplies from the delivery men
thus the delivery men have to be
extremely skilled combatants and we
primarily follow legendary 1 known as 5
8. sometimes he's called 5-8 sometimes
he's called 5A I'm just gonna call him
five eight from now on um but what you
need to know about him is that he's
basically a badass with a heart of gold
that would probably have the high score
on Crazy Taxi now throughout the season
he's slowly in its why so many refugees
are disappearing whilst the axis are
Mentor the one aspiring to join the
delivery men this is a refugee 34 who
originally lived in some of the
irradiated zones before he was taken him
by a woman known as the major and her
daughter it violates a lot of Harbor
refugees but he's managed to hide with
her whilst also doing deals with his
buddies out in the refugee zones they're
led by a character known as Grandpa who
becomes a big person later on gonna be
honest with you yeah whenever I cover
Korean shows I normally shot myself
thinking I'm gonna butcher all the names
but when they started calling them five
eight and Grandpa I was Bloody loving it
probably get in trouble for talking
about refugees all the time but moving
on it inside the 34 is basically a
mutant has the ability to rapidly heal
one day his apartment is stormed by some
soldiers and his sisters shot and killed
whilst he takes the Bullet to the Head
he manages to survive it though due to
his mutant abilities then he then Begins
the trials to become a delivery man
they're basically a big elimination
rounds that see him showcasing how much
of a nice guy is when he attempts to
help the other players out though the
CGI in the car scenes was a bit ropey I
actually really enjoy the turns that it
took and with shows like this you can
see why k-dramas continue to be some of
the best out there I also noticed in
episode 3 that 34 was wearing a Simpsons
top but they all had on gas masks which
was a nice little touch with everything
that was going on in the world whilst
they were filming it it was actually
pretty smart to incorporate masks into
the plot like this and it probably made
filming during the pandemic a hell of a
lot easier now normally when we're
dealing with post-apocalyptic stuff it
all gets tighter with Supernatural
things like zombies or aliens but this
managed to keep the focus on the humans
and still keep things intro investing
now as this tournament is going on we
see his 5 8 starts to investigate who
was behind the attack on 34 in his
family this leads him to uncover ayusuku
which I think I think I got that right
who is the wealthy heir to the chunyum
corporation as towards the end of the
season we learn the group has actually
been polluting the air through the use
of their cleanup Vans which are supposed
to be making things better he also
broadcasts the final round of the
delivery man tournament which brings in
refugees from around the area before he
has explosive set off that kill him he
also carries out a vaccination program
designed to wipe out the refugees and
yeah lots of social commentary I'm sure
people will be able to read into lots of
different ways now going against his
father the delivery men attempt to
assassinate rice silk but this ends up
failing ulena grandpa is and all that he
seems to be and that he's actually
friends with her are you suk's father
who's called Ryu we see that he burned
the QR code off his hand and would
rather live above ground without steady
oxygen than underground where it is he
also helped them make the air core which
converts the atmosphere into oxygen and
it allows the higher ups to have a
steady supply his garden shows that the
Earth of the South is getting its oxygen
back and that the world is now healing
Ryu wanted to give oxygen to the
refugees and move them to the general
area which his son was dead set against
due to the money involved in their
corporation he's also prejudiced against
the refugees because he doesn't see them
as being something that can offer
Society any benefits they have their
oxygen and those in the more structured
area all have QR codes therefore he sees
the refugees as a blight that steal from
his delivery men and the people he views
as being worthy of life now the entire
Arc with the father could be a
commentary on him switching from being a
capitalist into a socialist k-dramas
always have a wealth of political
subtext to them and there are those that
believe it won't work or they simply
don't want it to the Saku is stage and
ryu's killed during this with his son
assuming command the president is
captured by the defense minister and
this this gives both him and raiusook
control of Korea now he orders all the
delivery man to be tracked down which
takes us into the final part of the
Season exposing the medical program for
what it is and mounting up the delivery
men's storm rail 6 base whilst 34's
caught and captured by him and one thing
I haven't mentioned so far is that he
was bringing in lots of refugees to take
their mutant blood I think don't know
this whole thing it's kind of the
subplot of the subplot but it does
basically put 34 in a lot of danger now
what I'm bringing this up now is that we
can catch him at the end attempting to
deal blood transfusion with 34 and this
is so that he can take his abilities the
transfusion has to be stopped though
when Delivery Man reached the core and
the president is then saved the defense
minister is arrested which leads to the
soldiers surrendering making Ryu Suk
take on Desperate Measures he starts the
process of overloading the air core and
though he's taken down this still
explodes and destroys the capital
however the populists managed to make it
out along with the freed refugees and
the president announces the societal
structures are now being abolished
everyone will be viewed equally without
discriminate nation which leads into us
getting a three-month time Jump That
hints to where things could be going now
what does the ending of Black Knight
actually mean and what happens in it
well we pick up with five eight still
carrying at his duties and he finally
takes 34 under the world after his long
recovery we see that due to the lack of
rice explosion Vans at the air started
to clear and the harsh just storms at
once ravaged the land are disappearing
in the final moments 34 winds its window
down and both he and 5 8 are able to sit
with our gas masks off and breathe in
the air money even sticks his head out
the window to get a sniff of it and it
shows just how much the planet has been
turned around now what does this all
mean well I think the series is clearly
commenting on things like climate change
segregation and how Society is built
with infrastructures that hold per
people in place the corporation could
have easily helped the planet get
greener but they kept polluting the
atmosphere in order to make more profit
now this can very much be viewed as a
metaphor for real life as we have
several corporations that heavily
destroy the atmosphere but rather than
scaling things back they prefer to
expand their profit margins at the cost
of others well-being the way Ryu Suk
uses the refugees as experiments to
empower himself could also be seen as
symbolizing how workers are exploited
and used as pawns rather than being seen
as people you have a class struggle
going on here with lots of comments on
things like the pandemic keeping people
subjugated and also who actually runs
the show though we have a president
character it's clear that people in
charge are actually the corporations as
they Supply the oxygen and therefore the
jobs they have to keep people working to
remain profitable and this is why the
refugees are seen as being unnecessary
they don't contribute to the profits and
Rai succeeds them as being something
that will eat into his which is why he
has no problem when it comes to killing
them the corporation basically runs the
entire show and it also hands out the QR
codes which are what Society is built
upon they're happy to have people
fighting amongst themselves and even
trying to appear as the good guys by
giving out the free medical exams which
are of course deadly and to me what the
show is trying to say is that though
leaders and politicians can come and go
the main people running things will
always be these more permanent
structures I definitely think this
series is going with the idea that
equality is the way to lead to a better
future which is what I personally take
from the ending and what this means
going forward I don't know as there are
still some stories that they could tell
in this world however it does feel like
it has a conclusive ending and at the
moment there hasn't been a season two
announced I'm making this video on the
day of release though so things might
change but yeah let me know what you'd
want to see in a second season if we get
one that's what my thoughts in the
series I've got to be honest I wasn't
that impressed by the trailers I made a
pledge to cover as many Korean shows as
I can though because at that squid game
video it paid for my butt lift what but
after seeing that trailer I thought I
might just skip this however it's been a
quiet week so I gave it a go and I'm so
glad I did I think this is such a good
series and it works on a number of
levels pulling in lots of different
things that seem like they shouldn't
really work well together however they
work perfectly and are they add in lots
of things that seem like they wouldn't
really combine well I think that they do
you've got mutants combat tournaments
delivering stuff which I love political
coups and so on that tell us Amazing
overarching Story although it deals with
politics I think it's also something
that can be enjoyed by both the left and
right as you can clearly see metaphors
for both throughout the show I think it
works really well and it shows how
people are manipulated into doing their
bidding by those in power I definitely
think if you're interested in Korean
shows and you're looking for a good one
then this is definitely the one to watch
that's for my people who watch these
videos without actually watching the
show but yeah go check it out it's 6 45
minute episode so it's not even much of
a Time sink and think that you'll enjoy
it I bloody loved it I did and that's
why I'm giving it an 8.5 out of 10. now
obviously I loved you your thoughts on
it do you agree with this score do you
think it should have been longer are
there any problems that you had yeah
just comment below and let me know sound
a bit negative there say what you liked
as well if you did uh yeah and uh yeah
just talk about the show and what you
thought of it now as a thank you for
doing that we're running a competition
right now giving away the quantumania
steelbook to three subscribers on the
15th of May all you have to do be when
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
if you pick the comments out random at
the end of the month and the winners are
the last or not on screen right now so
that's you then message me on Twitter
out heavy spoilers if you want good
smells to watch then make sure you check
out our Brighton of the Easter eggs and
Evil Dead rise which will be linked on
screen right now so many good things in
that yeah lots of stuff to talk about
that ties back to the earlier movies and
if you enjoy that movie then head over
there after this other way thanks for
signature video I've been Paul and I'll
see you next time take care peace
foreign
[Music]